hey guys welcome to murder welcome
welcome to murdered by the [ __ ] up
[Laughter]
Freddy's back we could look at I just
like this is so cool hey so if I touch
them I die no I don't what are you
talking about if they touch me I die is
that how it works
oh yeah I'm gonna castrate them I wait
so how many are there this four right
yep there's no three then there's the
Fox waits the Fox I'm you can go outside
oh this map is so cool okay well you
can't tell me what to do
there's a Madrid in the loose Phantom
aquiline well that's kind of sexist it
could be a girl that is okay well hairs
it's probably a girl then yeah told you
call that okay so first of all we have
to cut the power
oh really what what happened whatever
were you talking about I saw a fox start
moving oh Jesus oh by the way the Fox
physically gets out and runs you can
actually like the other ones teleport
but he gets out and physically runs at
you it's really scary yeah we were like
oh yeah get the lights
oh yeah you can wear the hats there you
go beautiful no how does gravity work
why is duck I don't know what
oh are you supposed to stay in the room
is that it okay well let's all hang out
in the room then sorry
he's his ears are little shoes look at
that [ __ ] I want to wear those shoes
they're [ __ ] pretension follow me
don't worry alright what you do is you
grab a party hat make sure that you like
to party they need to know that you like
to party alright we got you took my
party hat what are you trying to get me
killed bird yeah we're good we're good
and now what we just well then I mean
what else would we do really oh hey look
at this jealous of our party hats again
join us wow group pressure oh [ __ ] open
the door hey I tricked you all wait
you're the murderer
why is it my gala game what is it it
thing is oh he's a good murderer what
the [ __ ]
that's a boxer sound like what that was
a fox
[Laughter]
[Music]
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait we're waiting for the Fox
wait come on ready for the Fox be cool
be cool okay grab a part head remember
that one time that we
and that was yes I'm so glad you
remembered this moment we had that was a
long time ago this a long long time ago
I'm glad you remembered that's whatever
you tried to take my sister out on a
date right or was that you I didn't even
know you had a sister but Oh God
take a hat and relax goddammit what the
murderer killed me wow what happened to
the memories man what the [ __ ] what do
you think Oh what the [ __ ] someone died
well I mean you have good party hat
ideas I am by 0.2 it makes everything a
bit more fun like a bit more relaxed man
whenever it's not ever to scared by this
show I'm going out I'm feel safe out
here what's in the window yeah it's like
a guy there okay what does he do he
likes to party nobody's like why was not
invited through the piece mom grounded
me stand there Romeo on the ground on
the ground I hereby dub you party
princess yeah you right now an award for
being party pretty good you now get to
DJ with Paris Hilton yeah oh no fit the
Hat it doesn't fit the face whatever
it's called there you go that works
pretty well actually a little bit kill
something to hide what the [ __ ] yeah you
smoke sorry I have really bad gas I just
familiar I I like to burn my you look
like pure evil right now piers like it's
just like to me it looks like my pubic
hair is on fire
maybe it's that maybe I spoke at your
feet pyromania like I need to use but I
got stabbed it isn't there supposed to
be a voice that doesn't tell me to do it
[Music]
that's the boy I waited for it what's up
with the Fox man you guys lied about the
Fox
uh check out that a stasis
what the [ __ ] should have expected that
okay where is he where do you think he's
gonna he's back in this hole oh yeah
well I saw it why did you try to shoot
me yes you did no yeah oh god my mom is
calling me mom I'm doing more important
man me damnit man leave the nice boy
alone oh well that was funny
I'm sorry guys mom is calling I'm not a
mama's boy I swear
alright yes you playing hey alright that
was actually old for that video if he
bros enjoyed it go ahead and hit that
like button as always I'm not a mama's
boy stay awesome roads